zach wilson from byu chris sims has him
as the top quarterback prospect to the
surprise
and and uh not delight of many who are
convinced trevor lawrence is the top guy
you spoke recently with wilson he talked
about
another former byu quarterback steve
young here's zach wilson
you think with steve young how
everything was so smooth in his career
when it's not
and i think that's what's interesting
about mine as well is is i wasn't a big
recruit
i didn't have a lot of offers i went to
byu as like
just a normal three-star recruit nothing
special and
nobody expected me to play early and you
know i ended up
having a chance to play as a freshman
you know something that i had to work
for but there was nine quarterbacks in
the quarterback room at the time and
then
wow you know even now i was i was nobody
um
last year you know and i was fighting
for my starting job back after my
sophomore year of having shoulder
surgery and things
you know things didn't go as well as we
wanted to and the coaches opened up a
competition to try and
earn the starting spot back and so i was
i was so determined to try and
you know win that job back and prove
that it was mine
you compared him last hour to joe burrow
in that
what a difference a year makes and what
a difference that that extra year made
for zach wilson
played a lot of games last year unlike
plenty of college programs
the competition level wasn't wasn't at
the same
level we saw from a trevor lawrence and
sims and i talked about that earlier in
the week and
and uh there's different ways you can
look at it but that's the reality and
that's part of the projection that teams
are going to have to make this year
can wilson perform the way he did
against a lesser level of college
defense
than what he's going to see in the nfl
didn't hurt patrick mahomes
he was able to step up and wilson could
too that's that's just part of the
challenge of scouting
but you know i agree with a lot of what
sims says about the guy i mean when you
watch his highlights he does just jump
off the
off the screen and he can do a lot of
the things that we've gotten
used to seeing from a guy like patrick
mahomes in recent years
mike i think there's a couple of things
about zach wilson that people
probably should know one is that
you know a year ago at this time as we
talked about uh briefly in the first
hour that
that uh he was not not only was he not
guaranteed
uh the starting job this year or
anything he was he was in a three-man
competition
for the starting job a year ago as kovid
began to
wreak havoc on the off-seasons of
college football teams
so what he did is he took the first
seven
weeks of everybody's exile
uh you know from organized programs
and went to southern california and
trained with his quarterback tutor
john beck you know while staying
enrolled at byu because he
there were no you know in-person
workouts or whatever
and then in the spring and summer after
everybody started to go back and things
were calming down a bit
he ended up driving 10 hours each way
on six or seven weekends between may and
late july
to work more with beck this guy is
is really driven to be a really good
player and i think the second thing is
if you look at the ball he throws okay
so he's like six two and a half
two ten he's not a big guy and he is
going to have to get
thicker as chris sims says but if you
look at some of the throws he made last
year
john beck would always teach him and he
would use this cliche he said you don't
want to throw the ball
to your receiver you want to be able to
throw the ball
through your receiver and if you look at
the toughest game he played all year
coastal carolina
at coastal carolina and people will
laugh at that but coastal carolina was
really good
last year they were a legitimate team
last year
he made some throws in that game that
any quarterback in the nfl
would love to have as much arm as he had
in that game
so look chris really stepped out on a
limb
in saying he's better than trevor
lawrence right now but i can tell you
mike i've talked to two coaches in the
nfl
who are very much who do not laugh at
chris sims i can tell you that
who really really like zach wilson and
that's why i think
there could be a second part of this
draft
okay i just don't think there's any way
that jacksonville
does not take trevor lawrence i i just i
don't i don't see it
but i do think that that creates
almost a second first overall pick
because i do think that everybody is
just gonna say okay
lawrence is gone now who's getting zach
wilson and
my feeling is that is where we might see
caroline at number eight denver at
number nine
maybe maybe and again we'll see there's
you know whatever 55 days before the
draft
we have to wait and see but to me i
think
we might have a sort of a second first
overall pick
and and so many people trying to go get
that second pick
with joe douglas of the new york jets i
still am fascinated though by the
possibility as
zack wilson gets more and more buzz and
i love a story of a guy
who became determined to get the
absolute most out of his abilities
and how many times do we see that being
the common denominator
for a high level of success in football
a guy who just decided i'm going to put
everything i have into this and get the
absolute most out of what i can do
but at some point does trent balke the
gm of the jaguars
say hey hey hey hey urban uh coach meyer
come over here take take a look at take
a look at some of these plays that i've
you know a lot of a lot of people really
like this what are are we sure
and you're not doing the job right if
you don't constantly ask yourself you
have to constantly ask yourself
are you sure are you sure and
all it takes is one time to say maybe
we're not sure
well mike in that you know to that point
i'll tell you two things brian
schottenheimer the offensive coordinator
of the jaguars
uh called uh john beck recently and had
an extended conversation with beck
about uh zach wilson uh was
very bullish on in fact that coastal
carolina tape
uh that i talked about a minute ago and
here's the other interesting thing
teams get to spend no more than
five zoom sessions with any prospect
the jacksonville jaguars have already
had two
zoom sessions with zach wilson now
i don't want that to you know i don't
want you to say whoa what does that mean
because they've also had two with justin
fields and they've had
i'm sure at least that many uh with
trevor lawrence
i i still think mike it's highly highly
doubtful that
they don't pick trevor lawrence that
but but as the star of zack wilson rises
and you know and urban meyer is still
getting used to the reality that there
is someone over him he found that out
the hard way three weeks ago with the
chris doyle miss adventures
but when you got the guy with the
handlebar mustache who can come in
anytime he wants and start asking
questions and you can't just tell him
please leave because he runs the show
and owns the team
you don't want you don't want you want
you want to be sure you've done all your
homework and you can make a good case as
to why you did what you did in the event
that for some reason trevor lawrence
doesn't work out
and zach wilson becomes a superstar
chances are both
are going to work out that's the thing
about as you said earlier quarterbacks
so much more prepared for life in the
nfl than they used to be
but uh it has to at least give the
jaguars
something to seriously think about and
if nothing else it makes them
more resolved that lawrence is their guy
but you know that's what teams do this
time of year they constantly think and
rethink and rethink and rethink and
there's a lot of cya that goes on before
you make that pick
there is mike and and look you know the
fact is
there's a very good chance trevor
lawrence is going to have a great nfl
career
and i think there's a very good chance
that zach wilson could have one too
and so i think you just have to look at
all of
your situation all around and
trevor lawrence does have one thing
that zach wilson doesn't and that is
a lot of big game experience
zach wilson doesn't have that you know
he he played some big games in his first
two years
at brigham young but he didn't play
anywhere
near the schedule of trevor lawrence and
what did trevor lawrence go
and 2 in in his college football career
so you know to me i don't think and look
i
i have tremendous respect for chris sims
because he's been right
so often about quarterbacks in the last
few years
but that's not to say that trevor
lawrence isn't going to be
really good in the nfl because his track
record
is certainly far and away the best of
anybody entering the draft this year at
quarterback
and sims fully acknowledges that i mean
i think in sims mind both guys are going
to be great he just believes that
wilson has a skill set that that has
comparisons at the highest of levels
in the current nfl and maybe in nfl
history when you talk about aaron
rodgers or patrick mahomes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports